so I have a slightly different take on
meditation and if you've been struggling
with meditation in your life this might
help I first thought believe in the
power of meditation I believe the
science I believe all the studies and I
used to judge myself and feel really bad
about it because I I felt like I
couldn't meditate I would sit there on
the couch or on the pillow or on the bed
or lie down and I never felt anything
when I was meditated I could sit and I
could be present and I could do it and
then and I could sit there for 20
minutes and it felt like 20 minutes but
I never felt any different I mean that
was where it started to shift for me is
not that I didn't feel anything in the
moment but never felt any different
coming out and I've meditated with some
of the best meditation teachers on the
planet and it's never really led to an
impact for me in the moment or
afterwards or sustained and I again
would judge myself really harshly like
hey I mean I want to make this work how
do I make this work I Believe In The
Sciences go and make it work what I've
distilled it down to is into two parts
one is a lot of meditation in a lot of
benefits I believe from meditation are
really just about being present and
being mindful I'm 85 present 15 future
focused and zero percent past Focus
hey it's Nina Carmichael and we made
these videos probably because you're the
most ambitious person in your circle but
you know you're capable of much more and
you get that Push by surround yourself
with the best so today let's learn from
one of the best my husband Evan
Carmichael and if you're struggling with
meditation in your life this video can't
help you enjoy
when you are thinking about the past
it's usually really negative way
sometimes we like pass Look Backwards
into the past and it's gratitude and
remembering great memories and
um you know looking all the great things
we've done but for the most part when
you look backwards it's negative it's
regrets it's I wish I did this or why
did that person do that to me I wish I
had said something different we're we're
looking negatively on our past mostly
through the lens of regret and what you
did or what other people did
and when you're looking forward
entrepreneurs love looking forward and
the vision and the building what you can
create and all the amazing things but a
lot of looking forward is also
uncertainty in Stress and Anxiety in
what may happen and what could happen
and what might happen if x happens and
just we're stuck in these negative Loops
a lot of the backwards thinking is
negative through the lens of regret and
a lot of the Forward Thinking is
negative through the lens of anxiety
stress and worry and so that's where hey
if you're present-minded you're going to
be a lot happier you're going to be a
lot more focused right if you're just
thinking about what you should have done
or what might happen to you you're not
actually able to be productive and get
stuff out right now in the present and
so the the job becomes how do I stay
present and I think a lot of that is
accomplished through meditation for most
people if you're if you're in a state of
stress thinking about the regret of the
past or anxiety about the future I think
meditation can be incredibly helpful to
help you get back to present even just
focus in on your breath breathe in
breathe out even something as simple as
that can help calm you down and get you
back to the present moment which then
allows you to
be able to be productive uh solve the
problem be happy because you're being
more present so for me that's actually
quite easy I'm in the present uh a lot
more than anywhere else and I used to
think it as a negative a friend of mine
used to make fun of me for having a bad
memory it's like you're such a bad
memory it's like and I later realized I
I don't have a bad memory I I want to
remember what's important to me but two
I'm not living in the past like I don't
care about what happened I'm looking at
right now today I don't know what day it
is I don't know what day it is I don't
know I I know it's 2022 when recording
this I'd have to think about what month
it is
I don't know what I'm doing after
recording this video I don't know what I
did yesterday I don't know what I'm
doing tomorrow let alone once I press
stop on this video I am here with you
this is this is my entire attention is
making this video right now that's it
this is this is the present moment for
me and what I've discovered is
this is meditation
at least the the portion of it where
you're getting back to present moment if
that's one of the main benefits of
meditation then this is meditation for
me I'm only in the present moment right
now being here talking with you guys and
that's it
and I realized that most of my life is
lived like that yes I love planning for
where I'm gonna go but most of my time
isn't spent in planning it's in in
executing in doing and I have to look at
my calendar to see what I'm doing
tomorrow or what I'm doing when somebody
asks me on a Wednesday what's your
weekend gonna look like
weekend I don't even know what I'm doing
in the next hour when I'm doing this
weekend and when people ask me on a
Monday how was your weekend like I don't
know
that was that was that was yesterday
that was two days ago I'm I got stuff to
do right now I'm working on my life
right now and and not just work even
just enjoying even just life even just
me spending time with with my wife or my
son or on a trip it's like let's enjoy
this moment where we're at right now and
so if that's you I would introduce the
idea of hey that's a different
perspective shift like maybe you are
meditating right now and you might be
over judging yourself because if you're
in the present that's one of the biggest
benefits one of my favorite things to do
every morning is I go on a belief walk
and I found when a lot of people would
say oh I get my best ideas when I'm
meditating if I get creative
breakthroughs when I'm meditating part
of that that I believe is hey you've
unblocked yourself from the past and the
future the regrets of the past the
stress of the future to get back to
present which then calms you down to
then that should be more creative and
solve the problem I found I wasn't
getting I wasn't really getting answers
I wasn't getting Solutions I wasn't
being very creative of sitting down
lying down and having my body be still
where I get a lot more of my energy and
creativity and ideas when I'm moving so
I get a lot of ideas
when I'm walking so I do a belief walk
every morning which is 30 to 60 minutes
I'll take the dogs out and then I'll go
for a walk usually the Tim Hortons grab
myself a coffee Canadian coffee brain
here and
No Agenda just think about what what am
I doing today you know what what day is
it what I want to accomplish today uh
take in some fresh air get a fresh
perspective and the the act of moving I
find gets my creativity flowing a lot
more I get ideas in the shower you know
when I'm when I'm moving have you got
ideas in the shower I think that's
meditation maybe it's a different
version of it a different definition of
it but I think that's meditation where
you can calm down when you can focus on
present and you get some great ideas to
come I'm selling my place we just bought
a new house we're selling this place and
the studio looks a little different
normally I'm filming in my car because
we're running some errands or my regular
studio and to get this place ready to
sell you you know we wanted to have a a
place that everybody could connect to
and so what my agent did was make an
office in a different room and I'm
sitting down and I have not sat down for
two years I don't know my last time I
like sat down to actually work and and
you might even notice me like I'm
Shuffling around a little bit like I
like to move normally I'm on a
trampoline and I'm bouncing 20 to 40 000
times a day and I got that because I
would find that when I did phone calls I
would much rather stand up and walk
around the office than just sit down and
so I'm a lot more creative and have a
lot more energy when I'm moving and
maybe that movement in my energy creates
movement in you know brain energy and
capacity and thinking creativity as well
but all of that is my form of meditation
and so anytime that I would challenge
you to at least consider the fact that
anytime that you're present
anytime that you are focused on
something that you can consider that
part of the benefits of meditation
the second part of meditation that I
haven't fully connected to yet and I
don't have a solution for yet is when
you access theta waves and that's
basically when you're bouncing between
conscious and subconscious and where you
feel like
time flies so for me when I sit down or
lie down doing a meditation
if it's 20 minutes it feels like 20
minutes and I don't think I'm hitting
any Theta levels
um I can sit there and be present and
focus on my breath or you know I've
chewed a cookie for half an hour or an
hour and never swallowed it you know
like the focus and the presence I can do
but it still feels like it's 20 minutes
or half an hour or an hour I've never
had a I sat down for an hour and I felt
like it was I was only on for five
minutes
I get that more through the work that
I'm doing I get that more
um I recently did a six hour uh q a with
Tom bilyu's impact community
on his Discord and
I was six hours I didn't go to the
bathroom I didn't take a break I was I
was reading the questions and answering
the questions my throat was burning
didn't even notice it till the end and
had that six hours flew where that felt
if you asked me how long was it I would
have said I don't know it was like
20 minutes half an hour like six hours
six hours later still going and then we
eventually wrapped it up because I
needed to go to dinner
my wife where I said yeah I'm gonna do
this short little q a and turned out to
be six hours
so maybe that's even a better form of
meditation maybe maybe when you're in
your purpose and doing great work and
time flies because you're having fun
maybe that is a better form of
meditation for you if you struggle with
just sitting down and meditating maybe
doing that work is healing you know I
think a lot of people meditate to heal
and I think of a part of why that could
work is because you're again removing
the stress of the past of the regret of
the past and removing the anxiety and
stress of the future and when your
body's all stressed out it's not going
to heal right but when you get back to
present and remove the stress you create
the conditions for healing in your body
well I remember when I broke my neck in
2019 and I kept doing my tour I kept
staying on it because I wanted to be
around entrepreneurs I wanted to keep
doing the I could have canceled the tour
wouldn't have been a big deal but that
became healing for me in feeling like I
was serving that I was helping sitting
at the front of a room for four hours
with
immobilized neck brace on ice packs you
know on my neck two or three pillows
behind me and I couldn't move for four
hours but just talk
that became healing for me
and so
at least what's helped me for where I'm
at right now I'm totally open to to new
experiences and being changed and you
know swaying my opinion before I'm at
right now
staying present
and doing
not just the work but doing activities
that you enjoy that you feel are in
service to others that you feel like
you're living your purpose that you feel
like you're having an impact think about
the things that you love doing where
where hours get lost I'm not talking
about like opening your phone and
scrolling through Instagram when you
realize that two hours have passed and
like how did I just waste all this time
not that but
in service of others and helping to see
I'm moving around right now I gotta move
I can't sit still
I don't like it when I get in creative
ideas I gotta move I play with my ring
you know they got the ring is all over
the place it's not just on my finger
this this gives me more creativity like
the motion creates more creativity for
me
and so if you find those things where
you love doing it's in service to others
is helping people time gets lost and you
feel it in your heart and your soul that
this is the right thing for you to be
doing for where you're at right now
that maybe that's you know maybe just
maybe that's the form of meditation that
you need the most
that
by staying present and helping others
and being in service maybe that's all
the healing that you need
maybe that is the present mind that you
need maybe that is the focus that you
need maybe that is the meditation that
you're already doing
and if that gives you some extra
perspective or a different view on
meditation than what you might hear
other places I hope that helps maybe
judge yourself a little bit less or
maybe lean into something that you
thought didn't exist because it
certainly played a huge impact on my
life and thank you for allowing me to
share the story with you rule number two
trigger yourself for Success the trick
to getting yourself into action mode is
to trigger yourself for Success
triggering yourself for Success means
you've taken the decision making out of
it that as soon as you come up with an
idea you have trained Yourself by
default into action mode you see your
brain will always talk you down from
things because it's trying to keep you
safe and it only understands a world
that currently exists that is logical
and practical until you learn to trigger
yourself for Success you will constantly
doubt your thoughts your ideas and your
actions this video is gonna help so
today I want to talk about this bag
right here a lot of you leave comments
so newer fans of the channel say why is
Doritos sponsoring your videos Evan why
don't you have a healthier sponsor don't
you know what bad Doritos does to your
body you should be promoting healthy
living
sponsor guys this is
triggering me for Success every single
day and this isn't just some tiny bag it
looks small looking back here but let me
bring this up look at that this is right
next to my face look at how big that
baggage Rita's is I have a strategy and
it's a weird strategy so maybe you'll
love it maybe you won't but I have a
strategy called Damn the Doritos I look
at this bag so I'm sitting this is how
I'm working right I'm not sitting I'm
standing I'm standing on a trampoline
this is my workspace right now right I'm
standing here I'm working in the corner
of my eye I got Steve Jobs up here and I
got I got this giant bag of Doritos all
I want to do is eat this bag all day
long I want to destroy this bag of
Doritos look at that giant ship oh
I'm gonna start drooling soon I love it
I want to eat that all day long
this bag is here as a reminder of how
great I am this is the mental
conversation inside my head Evan you're
awesome you're awesome for not eating
those Doritos every day and I want it as
a reminder people say it doesn't take a
lot of willpower
no it it builds for me at least builds
the willpower builds my strength every
time I see that bag of Doritos makes me
feel better about myself that I'm not
eating it and I have the strength to
keep going and so why I have that here
is when you're on a diet right this is
how it began when you're on a diet your
friends your family the experts will say
get rid of all the junk food from your
house get rid of it all because
otherwise you'll be tempted and then
you're gonna eat it and then you're
gonna ruin your diet I think that is
actually teaching yourself that you suck
you're teaching yourself I'm a weird
duck you're teaching yourself that you
are not strong enough to be around the
thing and so I need to get it out of my
environment the only way that I can
stick to this thing is if this other
stuff is nowhere close to me I think
you're telling yourself that you suck I
think it's a big crutch and just like
when you break your leg you have a
crutch your ultimate goal is to not have
a crutches to walk it's to run is to be
stronger than before right and so as a
step one maybe it's good right it's a
step one okay fine you broke your leg
you have a crutch you want to get on a
diet you're addicted to junk food get
out of the house awesome but as soon as
you go on vacation as soon as you go to
an office party as soon as you go to the
New Year's any kind of party you're
going to destroy the food because you've
trained yourself every day that you suck
that you're not capable I think you're a
genius I think you're stronger than you
think and so I tested it first with
myself and I thought you know what
Doritos are my Nemesis right I love
Doritos
oh my gosh she's looking at that bag so
I went to Costco and bought the giant
sized bag of Doritos and so I'm going to
put this on my desk all day long because
damn the Doritos because the Doritos are
stronger than me I don't think so right
I'm Evan Carmichael and same thing for
you
that thing that is holding you that's
that's stronger than you I don't think
so remember who you are remember how
strong you are and that's what this is
here for and it's been awesome to see
people now take this up a friend of the
channel uh LeRon was trying to get off
of sugar and he has a coffee cup with a
saucer and he drinks his morning coffee
and he put two packets of sugar on the
saucer right next to the coffee so he
pours his coffee has the sugar right
next to it and he just starts drinking
it and puts it down and looks at the
sugar packs and then just drinks the
coffee again and puts it down looks at
the sugar pack and his wife thinks he's
crazy and he's a little crazy too you
got to be a little bit weird duck but
but I think this is actually how you
build your strength
Mark Drake another friend of the channel
is addicted to the peak friends cookies
you know the ones that have the the red
on the inside and the cream in the
middle those are among my favorites too
and so his Co when he heard this went
out and bought all these boxes of peak
frames and put it on Mark's desk and he
opened it up and this is one of my
favorite things to do when whenever I'm
around Doritos or something I really
love to to eat not just say oh put that
away from me don't be around me I can't
have that and not just look at it I want
to smell it
so Mark took these cookies brought it
right up here Peak free cookies right up
here
oh and you can just see the Joy on his
face Jess as he's bringing back memories
and just what those cookies are gonna
taste like when they enter his stomach
and just um goodness everywhere right
the smile on his face maybe a little bit
of drool coming out you just oh
and then put the cookies down and walk
away
and how great that makes you feel as a
human to say here's one of my biggest
weaknesses of all time Bring It
I own you put it down and walk away
right I think that's how you actually
build strength by doing those difficult
things by triggering yourself for
Success every time I see the Doritos bag
I feel better about myself I feel
stronger about myself and I want you to
do the same thing if any of you are
gonna take on that kind of challenge I
want to hear you I want to follow you I
want to I want to see how your journey
is going because it's gonna be one of
the biggest most important life-changing
decisions that you embark on so now I
want to share three different success
triggers that can Propel you forward the
first is the boom boom test and that's
when your heart's going boom boom boom
boom boom boom boom boom right the idea
is we need to get out of our head we
need to get out of our head we get an
idea something something's coming at you
a new opportunity something that might
be scary we need to get out of our head
and just go off and do it right we're
taking the decision making process out
of it it's just understanding that these
things are the right things for me right
you have an idea it's a good one because
it came from you therefore it must be
good you're gonna do something about it
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom it's
your heart beating because you're
nervous because you're scared yeah
because you're afraid
teach yourself that when your heart's
beating that means it's go time whatever
the thing is
especially when it's other people's
opinions that you're afraid of you're
afraid of launching a YouTube video
because somebody's going to look at it
your friend your boyfriend girlfriend
high school friends parents husband wife
they're gonna look at and laugh at you
if that's the reason then you have to do
it just because right don't do something
stupid right don't don't don't go rob a
store because it makes you nervous okay
stick within your ethics but most of the
things you're afraid of are not stupid
things like going to rob a store their
fear of failing in front of other people
and if that's the reason then you've
lost for life and so teach yourself boom
boom boom boom boom you do it you stop
thinking about it and teach yourself
because when you find that I'm afraid
and I think action I'm afraid and I take
action I'm afraid and I take action what
you're doing is rewiring your brain
you're teaching yourself that you're
awesome that you're super strong that
you're a hero at least in your own mind
right I feel like a hero in my own mind
because when I my heart's going like
this boom boom boom that means I have to
go off and do it so use the boom boom
test number two is play bigger triggers
and these are things in your environment
that you can put in there to help you
play a bigger game so the Doritos is a
play bigger trigger for me right I set
it up once
it was a an idea that came to me and I
put it here I set it up once and every
day it triggers me forward it triggers
me to remind myself of how strong I am
because
I wouldn't I wouldn't do it from a
notification right I'm not gonna have a
notification in my phone every 20
minutes to say hey remind yourself how
strong you are remind yourself how
strong you are right this does it for me
automatically this the whole the room
here right these people all mean
something to me it means something the
plaques down there mean something to me
the the neck braces you can't really see
but under there there's my neck braces
from the tour right
I I wore this thing for 50 days and then
that one for 10 days or something like
that this is a reminder of how awesome I
am to myself right you might be looking
so why does he have a neck brace I'm not
so concerned what you guys think it's
for me there's a message here from my
wife right
I love you get well soon Hearts Nina
it's probably blurry you can't see it
but this is a play bigger trigger for me
I had a broken neck for 60 days and I
wore the same continued my tour right
you've done amazing things too in your
life this isn't about me it's about just
using an example you have already done
amazing things in your life you just
forgot you just don't remember how
strong you are
and so having play bigger triggers in
your environment that constantly remind
you of who you are and what you're
capable of makes a big impact on how you
feel about yourself and the third one is
scary difficult or hard when you hear
yourself say scary difficult to hard
this is the audio expression of the boom
boom test the boom boom test is your
heart beating boom boom boom boom boom
that's physical that's in the body some
of you may gravitate to that naturally
some of you may not catch that you're
you're you don't feel your body as much
but you're more auditory great so if you
ever hear yourself saying scary
difficult to hard same thing you do it
you do it you find a way to do it you
have to go off and do it because you do
scary difficult to heart because you
love scary difficult or hard and tell
your friends and your family the people
around you anytime you hear me say scary
difficult to hard
poke me in the stomach
he poke me in the stomach make me do it
right remind me remind me of what I'm
doing
because I think we play small by default
and we need those reminders on a regular
basis so the boom boom test to play
bigger triggers scary difficult to hard
because the opposite is is Comfort the
opposite is boring the opposite is
living your life every day the exact
same way it's photocopying your life
that's what most people do it's why most
people hate their life because they're
just photocopying it over and over and
over and over and over again you have a
chance to make a difference by
reprogramming your mind
because everything that you want that's
new that's exciting that's different
means you have to do something that's
new and different and therefore it's
scary so you love doing scary things you
have to if you want the life that you
want also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number three have a good
morning
routine nobody wakes up every day and
says this is gonna be the greatest day
ever not to unlock not Evan Carmichael
not Tony Robbins nobody you wake up and
you're tired and you have stuff in your
eyes and you have lines on your face
from the pillows the difference between
successful people is that they demand
Excellence from themselves to the habits
and routines that they do daily the
problem is that thinking that these
people are different that if you're not
waking up with tons of motivation ready
to take on the day that something is
wrong with you the only thing that's
wrong with you is you don't have the
habits that set you up for Success every
single day and today I want to change
that so I have a 5S morning routine that
I go through every single day that sets
me up for Success it demands Excellence
I'm gonna share with you guys today the
first s is sing the fastest way to
change your state is to put on music the
fastest way to go from feeling low
energy tired bored into an energy of I
am ready to go
is music
put on the song not that makes you feel
the current way that you're feeling this
is where most people mess up you put on
music for how you're currently feeling
if you're feeling really sad and low
energy you're gonna put on really mellow
slow music what does that do it keeps
you in the same state that you're in
it keeps you exactly where you are what
you want to do is put on the music for
how you want to feel and so I have a
playlist on my main Channel called the
believe playlist which is the songs that
I listen to these are the songs that I
listen to every day they may work for
you they may not work for you there's no
Perfect song for everybody this is a
perfect song for you and so build a
playlist of the songs that make you come
alive here's the criteria if this song
came on it would force you to start
moving if the song came on you find
yourself doing this if the song came on
you would get out of your chair and want
to move around doesn't mean you're gonna
dance like crazy doesn't mean you're
gonna start building out the lyrics that
may be you awesome but if you're a
little more introverted or don't like to
dance something that would make you move
something that would get you at least in
your chair doing this that's what I want
make a playlist and put that on it's the
first thing that you do every single
morning it'll make a huge difference to
setting the tone changing your state and
giving you energy and momentum to start
the day s number two is Sun I like
getting outside I think there's
something about getting outside of your
home of your condo your apartment
getting outside getting some fresh air
just being out in nature makes a big
difference getting some getting some
vitamins on your face from the sun
outside but also signifying that you're
you're leaving your bedroom you're
leaving the condo the apartment the home
you're leaving what happened last night
and you're ready to go off and start the
day this is especially important if
you're working from home because it's
easy to have your you know office right
next to your bedroom or maybe your
office is your bedroom and carry that
bedroom energy that tired I just woke up
I want to stay in bed I want to sleep
energy into your work and you won't do
great things if that's the energy you're
carrying to your work so having some
kind of ritual that splits up sleeping
energy to I'm ready to go energy makes a
big difference and I find the easiest
way to do it is to get outside and get
some sun bonus points if you're in a
condo apartment to take the stairs
instead of the elevator s number three
is sore and this is the most important
thing for me if you only take one of the
five I think this is the the most
important one to take what is the thing
that makes you soar every day what's the
thing that makes you feel alive bold
confident what is that and put it into
your morning routine at some point in
your life you felt both you felt
Unstoppable you felt confident it's
happened to everybody the problem is you
don't feel that way consistently every
day
you go through these bursts these
moments of man I could do such amazing
things but then the next day you wake up
and you're a different person you're
back to the I don't know if I can do it
I don't know who am I to go do this
crazy thing that's the problem
so whatever the thing is that makes you
feel like you can come alive that gives
you that boldness and confidence planet
with intention every single day into
your morning routine for me what I do is
I record a message on my phone to to
Instagram to my stories to I put it to
LinkedIn and Twitter right now I'm
putting it everywhere but I need to make
a message so I think of somebody that I
helped yesterday I think of somebody who
commented on a video who I met in person
who I coached on my Instagram live
somebody that I helped yesterday and
then I make a message channeling that
person I won't say the person's name but
I have them in my head I need to remind
myself that the work that I do is
important
it's easy to get lost in numbers it's
hard to imagine that two to three
hundred thousand people watched my
videos yesterday that's crazy it's a
wild number right it's wild it's hard to
like what does it even mean I don't know
I'm just sitting here talking to a
camera in my office and two to three
hundred thousand people are watching my
videos it's crazy I need to think down
to the actual person I need to think
about an individual that this matters to
somebody that the work I do really means
something to them and then I need to
record a message and share that helps me
soar and I do it every day
what is the thing for you what makes you
sore maybe it's watching the 254 series
that I put up every day maybe it's
watching the espresso videos like this
that I put up every day and some people
every day this is part of the morning
routine is watching an espresso video
and I'm humbled to be a part of your
morning routine for other people it
might be meditating they might be
watching a video or might be reading a
book listening to a podcast I don't care
what the thing is but you have felt bold
Unstoppable and confident at some point
in your life what led you to feeling
that way and then demanded of yourself
every day by putting it into your
morning routine the third s is sore it's
the most important one the fourth ask
for me is sweat
this is just about being healthy having
a healthy lifestyle and I want to do
something that makes me sweat so whether
it's a hit workout a cardio workout a
weights workout I put that into my daily
routine because I want to bust a sweat
and I want to stay healthy into my 40s
which is coming up and then into my 50s
and Beyond and then the last s for me is
scare I want to do something every day
that scares me what I'm doing right now
is to take a cold shower so after
sweating I need to have a shower they
want to show up to work all smelly and
so hop in the shower but right away
start turning the colder and colder and
colder and colder and colder and then
right at the very end I go all the way
cold and I freeze and even just stick
over right now
it sucks which is the best right you
want to do the thing that scares you
every day you're teaching yourself that
I do scary things so whatever is scary
for you whether it's taking a cold
shower whether it's making a phone call
whether it's sending an email making a
video and posting it doing scary things
teaching yourself getting that out of
the way right from the beginning I find
really helps me so that's the five Aston
morning routine that I go through every
day so you start by singing you get some
sun you soar you sweat and then you
scare when you're trying on different
habits imagine that you're just trying
on a hat you could take the 5S and try
it maybe they all work for you maybe one
of them works for you you try on my hat
and then some of it will fit some of it
won't quite fit the point of being able
to learn from people who've had success
is you take the routines you take their
habits and you see what works for you
because not all of them are going to
work that's okay don't judge yourself
don't say well Dan Lok does this and
Evan does this and Dwayne Johnson does
this and whoever else does that and say
well I can't measure up
maybe you don't want to work out four
hours a day like Dwayne Johnson does
that's okay you won't get the same
results right you're not gonna end up
looking like him if you don't work out
the same amount as him but that's okay
what is your definition of balance
what's the thing that makes you feel
come alive every single day and then
demanding it that's the most important
thing is you demand the Excellence from
yourself every single day by putting it
into your morning routine instead of
hoping that amazing things happen and
waking up like an accident rule number
four love the process there are three
main reasons why people don't put in the
work that you need to win three big huge
reasons that if you fix you'll start
seeing the momentum in your business and
your life explode so let's just dive in
look at all three and see which one is
your problem reason number one is you
don't want it badly enough this is
unfortunately the case for tons of
entrepreneurs you say you want something
and looks good is a huge opportunity
something is blowing up in 2020 it's the
industry everybody has to get into but
you actually don't want it that badly
enough you don't care enough about the
thing you're chasing some outcome
instead of actually loving the process
of the work and I think it's it's way
too many entrepreneurs one of the
biggest reasons why so many
entrepreneurs fail is because you just
actually don't want to think about
enough you're just chasing an
opportunity instead of actually loving
the thing so a good question to ask
yourself is do you actually love this do
you want it badly enough I love making
videos I sucked at the beginning I'm
still working to get better I've gotten
better over the you know decade I've
been on YouTube I still look forward to
it I still love it I still work every
week creating content for you guys we're
putting out six videos a day across the
different channels now it's it's wild
it's crazy and I still love it we're
putting in the work I'm putting in the
work my team's putting in the work
because we still actually love the
process of doing it so so many
entrepreneurs quit and give up because
you'll say you'll do whatever it takes
but you're not going to if you don't
actually love the process you don't
actually love the work you will not do
whatever it takes you will only force
yourself to do something that you hate
for so long until you give up and quit
so a big reason why entrepreneurs don't
put in enough work because you just
don't love it stuff the second reason
why entrepreneurs don't put in the work
they need to win yet is because you're
not strong enough yeah you're not strong
enough starting a business is hard it's
really hard it's it's I mean it's among
the hardest things you're ever going to
do in your life I don't know many things
that are harder than starting the
business and making it successful it
requires so much of you it's it's an
extra child
it's an extra child it's crazy it's so
much work and it's going to require you
raising your standards it's going to
require you breaking way out of your
comfort zone it's going to require you
becoming a new version of yourself it
just will
entrepreneurship is the best personal
development program on the planet
because who you are before you become an
entrepreneur has to change it doesn't
mean it's a you become a totally
different person it's a better person
it's a better version of you it's it's a
stronger person of you it's like before
you've gone into the gym you're you know
super weak and scrawny but if you go
into the gym every day you come out 10
years later you're going to look
different and you're still you but just
better stronger right that's
entrepreneurship the problems that
you're facing right now that seem
overwhelming they they can't be
overwhelming to you you have to
understand that this is just a starting
point this is just a warm-up for you
you're capable of way more than this
because if this is all you're capable of
doing then you're not going to do more
then that's your limit but I don't think
it is your limit I think people live way
more for me to make videos my first
video took me two days to make right
took two days two days to
um to film and then editing that should
probably take more than two days it took
me a long time to make one video and now
we're cranking them out
because I'm better because I've learned
that what used to be impossible if you
told me then when I was starting that I
I'd be making 6 000 videos and six
videos a day and all these channels
you're crazy that's not what I'm gonna
do
but then as you get into it you start
playing the game you start growing you
start getting stronger you're capable of
way more so a big reason why
entrepreneurs don't put enough work
because it's just too hard you just see
it as too overwhelming it just feels too
impossible it requires you to grow it
requires you to raise your standards it
requires you to expect more of yourself
and to become a stronger person a
stronger leader a stronger man or woman
it requires you to become stronger and
increase those standards and and some
people aren't willing to do it
some people don't want to grow yet some
people get overwhelmed by it and so they
don't put in the work but if you're
struggling
all of your struggles are on the other
side of you growing as a human and
you're getting stronger and having the
capability the mindset that you have the
capability to go off and Conquer that
goal and the third reason why
entrepreneurs don't put enough work is
they're too focused on excuses over
winning there's a million reasons I like
to say there's a million reasons why
you're not going to win right there's so
many reasons why you're not going to win
there's so many things you can blame
that you can blame your parents you can
blame the economy you can blame the
president you can blame your high school
class like there's so many reasons
there's so many it's not your fault
right there's so many reasons why you're
not winning a million reasons why and
you start talking to your friends and
the people around you they'll find a
million more reasons and it's so
comforting to stay in those excuses it's
so comforting to know that it's not my
fault that I'm not winning it's my
parents fault it's my sister's fault
it's my my high school teacher's fault
right because he he threw a ball at my
head in gym class and so now I'm not
successful right like it's so comforting
to stay there because it means you don't
have to grow it means you don't have to
change it means you don't have to do
anything else different where the people
who actually go off and win and put in
the work they're focused on the winning
the focus on the winning instead of the
excuses they stop hanging out with the
people who are focused on excuses most
of your friends probably focus on
excuses the people who you went to high
school with probably are focused on
excuses there might be one or two who
are off crushing it and focused on
winning most people focus on excuses and
so you don't want to hang around most
people until you're strong enough to
pull them into your gravitational field
instead of you getting sucked into
theirs right you're so great you're so
confident you're so strong that you're
going to be a light for other people and
they're gonna get sucked into your
energy as opposed to you being around
mediocrity and you've fallen down you've
Fallen back steps and you're hanging out
and becoming them right whoever is more
confident wins they're very confident in
their mediocrity and so they're going to
pull you into it unless you're insanely
strong and confident in your ability to
do great things and so think about why
you're not winning
why what's the reason what's the reason
you're telling yourself go look in the
mirror now she said why am I not more
successful why have I not hit my goals
whatever the reason it comes back
has to be something about you getting
better if it's well because of this this
this this this this and this and just
listen off excuses then you're not going
to win you just won't you won't put in
the work that's why people don't make
the sacrifice
because they're focused on excuses
instead of actually winning rule number
five the last one before our very
special bonus clip develop new skills
you will never lose in life if you have
valuable skills you won't lose your
house you won't lose your car you won't
lose your clients if you have a skill
that brings people value the economy can
collapse the algorithms can change but
as long as you have a skill that solves
problems for people you will be safe so
I'm seeing this a lot in the YouTube
world now I have a new course out
helping people get to a million
subscribers on YouTube we can link up
the description there if you want in and
people are saying well should I still do
YouTube is it too late like YouTube
won't be here in five years or ten years
or maybe it's gonna be the next thing
that should hop on it's not about the
platform like right now it's winning the
platform that is currently winning you
need to crush it right like YouTube
should be your home if you're trying to
make an impact you're trying to be a
thought leader you have a message to
spread YouTube has to be your number one
place it just has to be right now
otherwise you're not making a smart
decision but whether YouTube still
around in 20 years five years doesn't
matter because the skill set that you
learn you can take anywhere the ability
to communicate you could take to any
platform you could take to the next
thing I don't anticipate YouTube still
being around in 20 years but my ability
to make videos talking to a lens
that's not gonna go away that can serve
me for life right whether that's VR Evan
or hologram Evan you know coming into
your living room that's that's gonna be
me that's gonna be amazing I'm pumped I
look forward to it
any algorithm change that people are
freaking out about anybody who's
complaining about the economy going down
or the algorithm changing you've already
lost that's a losing mindset when I was
first starting my YouTube channel
uh I always saw the algorithm as a
chance to win right you should see if
you're a small Creator on any platform
YouTube Instagram anything and the
algorithm shifts that's your greatest
Advantage you should be cheering you
should want more algorithm changes if
you look at a traditional established
boring Market uh it's hard to win real
estate could be hard to win right
financial markets can be hard to win not
that it's not possible it's just hard to
win because there's a lot of people who
have who have Decades of experience no
more than you and it's hard to close
that gap of experience
with social media with YouTube every
time there's a big algorithm change the
people who are experts at the last thing
they're crying instead of adjusting
that's how you win that's how you get
ahead of them that's how you become the
top dog is because you're gonna go learn
the new algorithm when everybody is
wishing and hoping that the old
algorithm comes back and this happens
for every platform it happened for
Facebook every time they change your
algorithm or updated the the feed and
what was shown there people always freak
out and complain and they sign they want
petitions and like let's go back to what
it used to be don't sign those petitions
don't jump on that bang when that is
loser thinking never ever ever ever ever
ever ever do that it's loser thinking
and that's how most people think
that's a mindset shift that I want to
make for the collective but more
importantly for you
that whenever there's a big change
embrace it go all in on it learn it
that's how you're gonna LeapFrog
everybody else so the faster the rate of
change the more you should be cheering I
still get pumped for an algorithm change
me I mean now I'm at now I'm closer to
the top right I mean I don't know what
the top is I got too many subscribers
and 300 million views and all these
channels I still love it anytime an
algorithm change comes out I'm still
pumped train yourself Like A change is
coming I'm pumped get excited because
there's still people who are ahead of me
or even the people below me that I'm
competing with for for attention and for
space if they're sitting there
complaining about how it's changed and
they're dropping in their views awesome
I'll pick up those views because I'm
going to learn what the new algorithm is
all about
same thing with the economy when the
economy crashes everybody who's
complaining about how it used to be
they're not going to win it's comforted
to join a club and wish things could be
how they used to be but we're not going
back to that
So the faster you realize that and make
improvements the faster you can learn
and actually build a great business some
of the greatest businesses in the world
were built in recession in depression
that could be you if you decide to be
let's hop back to skills for a second I
look at Jake Paul Logan Paul they
started on Vine right Vine was was their
claim to fame they had tons of success
in making these super short videos Vine
gets shut down right boom gone this is
don't put all your eggs in one basket I
think that's loser thinking too it's
loser thinking
they went all in on Vine and and then
Vine got shut down oh no what do they do
they moved to YouTube and started
crushing it millions of subscribers look
at their growth on YouTube over the past
I don't know two years three years blew
up why
didn't just come out of nowhere they had
the skill set they had the skill set
that they learned from doing the thing
right the skill set to make a good video
they then brought to a new platform if
YouTube goes away
you're learning the skill set of how to
communicate how to make great videos
that whatever comes next
people are freaking out about the FTC
coming in and Kappa on YouTube okay so
if kids aren't able to get content on
YouTube where they're gonna go go be
there
instead of trying to fight what is
already happening
go be at the place where the kids are
going to be
embrace the change
that's where you that's where you can
win when everybody else is fighting and
angry and screaming and yelling and
complaining and wishing that it used to
be or quitting the platform and getting
upset go be where they're gonna be it's
it's easy it's a simple win most people
don't have that mindset it's why most
people lose why most businesses can
evolve most businesses shut down it's
people very rarely transition from one
platform to another from one business to
another even though they have the skill
sets and capabilities to do so because
they don't have the mindset to do so
people who crushed Myspace very few of
them are still around
on different platforms look at look at
Hollywood the rock is doing it Will
Smith is doing it moving from Hollywood
films to YouTube where's Brad Pitt
where's George Clooney like they're in a
dine industry they should be embracing
YouTube they don't want to they have the
skills they have the skills it's
transferable you don't think George
Clooney could come in and Crush YouTube
if you wanted to
of course you could calling you out
George Clooney let's go make it happen
all right it's just about picking up the
skill set that will keep you safe in any
environment but it's also having a
mindset to follow through and try the
new things instead of complaining about
the changes that are currently happening
so how can you do it I'm gonna give you
a three-step process that I think will
help Step One is make sure your actions
map to your missions this will help you
determine what skill set you need what
are your Ambitions what do you want to
accomplish what do you want in our life
there's so many ways to win you know if
you've gone through the Hawaii how
process you know what your purpose is
you know what you're trying to
accomplish you've you've read built a
survey you can't read it yet still in
pre-order but you understand the concept
you figure out your purpose great to
actually go off and accomplish it what
are the skill sets that you actually
need what are the skill sets you need to
develop even if you suck at it if you're
not naturally good at it I'm introverted
I'm not naturally good in front of the
camera it took me 6 000 videos to get
here right I got better with practice
and repetition and dedication and hard
work and all of that you can too what
are the skill sets that you need to
acquire to get the life that you want
and then you can start working on them
so first step is figure out how do you
map your actions to your Ambitions
second step is to learn to tell yourself
that it's the best it's the best it's
the best every time something negative
is happening to you the economy is
crashing and algorithm is changing a new
competitor comes in something something
negative is happening you tell yourself
it's the best this is the best is my
chance to prove to myself and the world
what I'm made of when an algorithm
changes and you say it's the best you're
gonna find a new solution
if you sit there and complain and get
negative and toxic you're not going to
find a new solution the best part of
saying it's the best is it shifts your
mindset from one of complaining and lack
of resourcefulness to one of ultimate
resources to be able to say I'm gonna go
solve this thing let's go it shifts your
mindset so many people get stuck in the
negativity even if you're an
entrepreneur and you're positive and
optimistic and have great hopes for the
future of where you want to go if you
spent all this time and energy building
up this thing and it gets taken away
from you
it's really hard to say this is the best
but that's what you need to do because
otherwise you spend the rest of your
life living off of past glory to say
well this is what I used to be and it
was all taken away from me and now life
sucks like you want the next 40 Years of
your life to be thinking like that
the economy crashes
algorithm changes the
system you're gonna question new
competitor comes in it's the best you're
gonna crush it right
you grow through difficult times you get
better to a difficult time you don't
want to do the same thing over and over
and over and over again that's boring
that's photocopying your life that's not
what you want you want to grow you want
to progress self-confidence self-love
all of it comes from doing difficult
things by telling yourself that when
that difficult thing comes it's the best
this is my chance to rise up and show
myself and the world what I'm capable of
as opposed to saying this sucks and
sitting in negativity all day all week
all month all year all decade and step
number three is understand that the
quantity leads to the Quality we figured
out what our skill is that we want to
get good at right we understand that
it's the best that when other people are
complaining we're going to rise up and
improve our skills and get better at the
thing because that's how we're going to
win and now number three is the practice
The Daily Grind the constant Improvement
I've done six thousand videos is how I
got better at this the thing that you
want to get great at you have to do a
lot of you're going to suck at the
beginning you're not going to have any
quality that's okay that's great it's
the best right but then through
repetition through practice through
daily hustle attacking the thing the
thing that you love doing even though
other people see it as work and torture
you love it you're getting better at it
that's how you're going to improve your
skills every skill set is possible to
acquire just a skill doesn't mean you
suck as a human just means you don't
have the skill set yet how do you get
the skill set by practicing
quantity leads to the quality and so
back to point number one of your actions
map to your Ambitions how much are you
practicing you want to acquire the skill
set how much time are you actually
spending on that skill set you want to
be a great editor great how much time
you spending editing you want to be a
great piano player how much time you
spending piano
right you might have some natural
ability for it awesome and if you don't
I had no natural ability to be good in
front of the camera go back and watch my
first videos you'll see you'll see how
much I sucked no natural ability zero it
took a long time
practice dedication hard work right
action snap to your Ambitions by putting
the quantity that leads to the Quality
how much are you doing show me your
calendar show yourself your calendar
pull up your calendar look at your next
week look at your next month that skill
that you want to acquire it's going to
save you from the recession from the
algorithm change that's going to bring
people value that skill that you need to
acquire it's going to pay you
how much time you spending developing it
and if it's not a lot if it's not
sometime every day you gotta change your
mindset you got to change your calendar
you need to change your actions because
right now if that's you your actions are
not mapping to your missions I want you
to win you need to get the skill sets
that's the path
the biggest mistake so many
entrepreneurs make is they jump into a
business because they see that it's a
hot opportunity you don't love it you
don't know much about it but so many
people are talking about it and it looks
like an easy way to make a lot of money
big mistake don't do that it's the
fastest way to go broke so Warren
Buffett did not invest in Amazon but
he's still done pretty well for himself
he didn't invest in Amazon because he
doesn't like Tech he doesn't know it he
doesn't love it he doesn't live in that
space and so he doesn't want to buy
those kinds of companies and great he
missed out on Amazon but he also missed
out on all the tech companies that
didn't make it that he could have put
money into that just would have gone to
zero he knows what he's great at he
knows what he loves and he sticks in his
Arena I look at what I'm doing there's
so many opportunities that come my way
that I know nothing about I have no
interest in I don't want to have
interest in that I'm I'm losing money on
right I don't like real estate I hate
real estate I don't wanna I don't want
to be in it I don't want to learn about
it I don't like real estate it's not
that it's not a good good opportunity
it's just not for me it's boring to me I
have zero interest in real estate it's
great for so many people so many people
have built amazing wealth and
generational wealth based off of real
estate amazing I'm pumped for you it's
just not the thing that I want to be in
cryptocurrency right people when Bitcoin
was taken off everybody was a
cryptocurrency expert I know nothing
about cryptocurrency I bought zero
cryptocurrency in my life I've been
given zero cryptocurrency in my life is
cryptocurrency the future yep when is it
gonna come I don't know is it going to
be Bitcoin I don't know I I don't know
anything about the cryptocurrency I get
the mechanics and the general theory and
I know that it's coming but it's not the
opportunity for me
CBD is a big thing now right everybody's
getting the CBD and CBD oils and CBD
products and great and it's becoming
legal here in Canada or it already is
legal in a bunch of our provinces and
it's going to be legalized across many
states if not the whole country
awesome
I don't smoke
in it it may help you it may alleviate
your pain amazingness may be the
greatest gift you've ever seen in your
life amazing but if you're only jumping
into it because you think it's a hot
opportunity You're Gonna Lose
that being said I'm also involved in so
many things that are hot opportunities
I'm drowning in Opportunities I have too
many opportunities that I know what to
do with let alone don't know what to do
with looking at YouTube you YouTube
right now is still a massive opportunity
there's so many people who look at what
I've done who look at what Gary have
done and Grant Cardone and those guys
have done is say I want to do it YouTube
is blowing up it's popping it's
exploding if you're a thought leader if
you want to have educational content
YouTube is still a huge opportunity most
people who are the experts at what they
do are not on YouTube that means you can
go on even with a little bit less
expertise and go and crush it because
the people who are the best in the world
are doing it they're not doing it it's a
huge opportunity it's a big white space
still right now even though I've been on
it for 10 years YouTube has evolved a
lot over the past decade and there's
still tons of white space open and
available I need to push the opportunity
harder I look at thought leadership is
another one thought leadership the stuff
that I'm doing the videos like this the
teaching that I've done the workshops
that I've done people want to be a
thought leader not just an influencer
but a thought leader and I'm at the
center of that Trend I'm helping train a
lot of thought leaders people are coming
to me asking me for help in becoming a
thought leader and making content and
being able to do good videos and be able
to get speaking gigs book deals all of
it people want it it's happening and I'm
at the center of that Trend too League
of Legends I love League of Legends I've
been playing League of Legends for this
is six years this is my six year playing
League of Legends I've played Teemo look
I got I got I got Teemo here I got Teemo
here I got Tristana here I've named my
dogs Timo and Tristana right I play
three games a night on my twitch stream
you can come to my twitch stream
twitch.tv believeteam come join me I
play there three games a night I'm
trying to get the gold uh this season
which means I'm in the top 10 of players
uh in North America so that's my it's my
ambition for the year I watch League of
Legends every weekend I have a TSM
Jersey let me get it
I have a TSM Jersey I'm a fan I love
League of Legends I love Esports if you
are getting to Esports just because it's
a hot opportunity and you don't love it
you're gonna die You're Gonna Lose I
look at garyvee as an example and Gary's
done an amazing job in hip-hop an
amazing job in hip-hop and he's brought
so many different artists on from the
top of nipsy hustle all the way down to
people who are just breaking in and
trying to get their start he loves
hip-hop he loves the lyrics he loves the
culture and so he's really built a name
for himself inside of hip-hop he got
into twitch a little bit he had a twitch
Studio set up in his office and he
started doing a little bit of gaming but
he's not a gamer he hasn't done gaming
in decades and so it's not authentic for
him and so he's not gonna win there I
love Esports I love League of Legends I
love gaming it's part of what I do I can
talk to you about the current roster for
TSM and my thoughts on it I could talk
about the new patch that came out on
League of Legends and how timo's doing I
like it it's just I genuinely like it
and so I have these opportunities in
front of me already within YouTube
within thought leadership within Esports
that that I can take advantage of and
blow up in and I don't need to worry
about real estate and cryptocurrency and
CBD and all the other millions of
opportunities out there there's already
tons of opportunities inside the things
that you already know and love the
things that you know and love there's
lots of people who know and love that
thing too
and they're looking for guidance they're
looking for help they need answers you
could be the person who gives them the
answers
jumping on some train because you think
it's a hot opportunity and a chance to
make money is the fastest way that you
will lose money because you don't
understand anything about that if you
don't love Esports don't go spend money
on an Esports team
inside the
tip I know is a tremendous opportunity
and that's what you need to focus on
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome and if you
want to watch Evan's top 10 rules for
Success check out the video next to me I
think you can enjoy continue to believe
I will see you there going broad is the
slowest game but the most sustainable
game so winning on YouTube for example
it's the it's the hardest to get going
because people don't know who you are
yet you got to build your brand you got
to get great message from the camera get
comfortable